[Music]
there is no doubt that Disney songs are
some of the best music out there they
are always super catchy and stay with us
forever but not every Disney song made
it into the movies stay tuned to find
out which song was too good to stay in a
movie
hey Disney lovers be sure to subscribe
for all sorts of Disney news and trivia
now let's find out about ten Disney
songs that were cut from the movies
human again it's a tale as old as time
movies undergo a lot of edits and
changes before the final version and
fans never see a lot of what happens
behind the scenes Beauty and the Beast
is no exception in the 1991 film it gave
us some of the most iconic Disney songs
ever it's a sweet but one major song was
cut from the original version human
again was all about the household staff
dreaming of becoming well cuban again it
was cut for several reasons first the
original sequence was 11 minutes long
they did cut it down though so why
didn't it stay well the song was
supposed to span months which created a
huge plot hole what was Bell's father
doing for all those months was he just
wandering around the forest they cut the
song but it was included in the Broadway
version and the 2002 re-release of the
movie it was absent again in the
live-action movies starring Emma Watson
why me the year 1992 gave us Aladdin and
the thief turned Prince stole our hearts
there are some amazing songs in the
movie like a whole new world and Robin
Williams's iconic friends like me
[Music]
but several songs were cut from the
movie one of them was why me this song
was meant to be sung by Jafar in the
song he basically complains about why no
one has ever appreciated him it totally
shows how full of himself Jafar really
is he sings it alongside the bird Iago
but most of the songs like this one were
cut for time and to streamline the plots
proud of your boy speaking of Aladdin
did you know we were supposed to meet a
Latins mom in the movie can you imagine
that the song proud of your boy was
supposed to be signed by Aladdin it's a
song that will get you right in the
fields in it he apologizes for
disappointing his mother and promises to
make her proud as the story changed the
creator's found that they didn't really
need Aladdin's mother as a character she
just didn't add much to the story once
they cut her there was just no need for
the song we wonder if Aladdin's mom will
be in the live-action movie in 2019
maybe some of the cut songs will make it
into life's too short
sometimes when you're editing movies you
just have to decide to let it go and
that's what happened in frozen when Ana
goes after Elsa in the mountains they
were supposed to sing a song called
life's too short in it they argue
because Ana wants to not only restore
her relationship with Elsa but she also
wants Elsa to come home and fix the
eternal winter she caused Elsa doesn't
want to go back though the song also
refers to a prophecy as the storyline
changed this song was cut and replaced
with the reprise of for the first time
in forever
[Applause]
I will be bright he they were supposed
to be a reprise of life's too short as
well when Elsa feels guilty for
accidentally freezing Anna but that got
cut to dancing on a cloud way back in
1950 Disney released Cinderella the
movie has stood the test of time and
Cinderella is still one of people's
favorite Disney Princesses there was a
song in the original concept called
dancing on a cloud in it Cinderella and
the prince became so mesmerized dancing
together that they end up well dancing
on a cloud Walt Disney himself designed
the storyboards for the scene ultimately
they cut it for time and just kept so
this is love but the cloud dancing scene
made an appearance a few years later in
Sleeping Beauty - the song Morning
Report Simba definitely made a mighty
king and he learns from the best Morning
Report was an adorable scene at the
beginning where Zazu the Bird Sings all
the news of the kingdom - Mufasa
but Mufasa and Simba don't quite take
the dazu as seriously as he takes
himself the song was cut from the
original version way back in the
storyboarding stage but it was in the
original Broadway version then it was
animated and recorded for the re-release
in 2002 when the DVD came out
but it didn't quite stand the test of
time it was cut from the Broadway
version of Lion King in 2010 after 13
years in the show I'm awed in Alice in
Wonderland Alice descends into a world
of nonsense
just as the Arthur Lewis Carroll
intended but there was even more
nonsense in the original concept there
was supposed to be a whole sequence
based on Lewis Carroll's poem
Jabberwocky
but good old Walt Disney decided it was
both too long and creepy af this
sequence was cut and as a result the
song I'm awed was mixed - this song was
sung by the Cheshire Cat and he really
is extremely odd they kept some of the
same sentiment and lines of the poem in
the song twas brillig we're just glad
they didn't cut the Cheshire Cat middle
of the river Disney's Pocahontas gave us
some of the most beautiful anthems like
colours of the wind and just around the
Riverbend
[Music]
but another song was cut from the final
version and it's totally gorgeous middle
of the river was a duet between
Pocahontas and John Smith it was how
they could be together when there was so
much hatred from their people it's an
absolutely stunning duet and the
songwriter Stephen Schwartz said it was
the best song that was cut maybe one day
we can see it in a rereleased version
that would be awesome
I can't believe my heart Nagara is the
fierce lady who steals the heart of the
demigod in Hercules
she sings an amazing jazzy song called I
won't say I'm in love which shows her
denying that she actually has feelings
for the handsome Hercules but there was
another song that she was going to sing
instead I can't believe my heart would
have been sung at the same time in the
movie this song is a lot slower and
sounds more like a traditional love song
it was cut because it just did not fit
Meg's personality at all she is just not
that lovey dovey it's still a great song
though someday we understand cutting
songs that don't fit the characters or
the storyline but can you imagine
deleting the song because it's too
amazing that's exactly what happened in
the hunchback of notre dam after
Esmeralda seeks refuge in the Cathedral
she sings an epic ballad the songwriters
wrote two songs for the scene god help
the outcasts and someday the creators of
the movie decided to cut some day
because it was too powerful they opted
to give as morale to the more humble
song it didn't get totally nixed though
you can hear the song and the end
credits it will leave you shocked which
Disney song do you wish hadn't been cut
let us know in the comments and those
are 10 Disney songs that never made it
into the movies for more awesome content
don't forget to subscribe and give this
video a big thumbs up
[Music]